good morning believe nation today's
message is be restless over to you Sean
Parker I think there's also a
restlessness that all really good
entrepreneurs have and it comes from
curiosity wanting to understand the
world wanting to find some problem
that's unique where you have a unique
solution to that problem and once you've
done it in one industry you're going to
try to do it in other industries and
you're going to try to do it in areas
that maybe are unrelated to business
Mike philanthropy or politics or some of
these other places I think a blessing
and the curse of entrepreneurs is that
we're always Restless you're always
thinking of new ideas we're in the
shower camp with a thousand different
business ideas we could walk into any
company and come up with other ideas for
them to do and we always have ways for
things to be better that's part of what
is just in us and we want to help the
world get better we always see new ideas
but I think in terms of being Restless
deep down it comes from caring you know
the more you care about something
someone some project that you're working
on the more it's going to keep you up
the more you're going to toss and turn
the more you're going to have it in the
back your mind I think it's
entrepreneurs we can never really shut
off our business does not we try for
work-life balance but you're always
thinking about your business it's always
there because you care so much about it
right you know just of if you have a
sick family member you're they're always
going to be in your mind you're caring
for them this morning i woke up at five
in the morning i'm usually up at seven
something so it was extra early for me
because today I'm giving some people
advanced copy of my book to review and
this is the first time that's been put
out for anybody else to see and so I'm
nervous I'm excited about it and so I
woke up early just naturally because I'm
Restless right I care about it and so I
think it's a good thing you know I think
I think being too Restless is obviously
a negative but I think how in some
degree of restlessness shows that you
are
caring about something and if you don't
have any then it kind of means like you
don't care enough about some things in
life and you might have to boring a life
and so you might need to up the caring
quotient on what you're doing with your
life and in your business so the
question of the day today is what are
you restless about right now what are
you worried about right now what keeps
you up right now leave it in the
comments below I'm curious to find out
I'm going to join the discussion with
you guys thank you so much for watching
have an amazing day continue to believe
and i'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot events presser